[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
marc fesneau bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous au ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale représenté
par fabrice bonjour bonjour et on
commence avec cette censure du conseil
constitutionnel marc raynaud l'essentiel
de la loi à vias et la loi qui vise à
encadrer à lutter contre les contenus
haineux sur internet qui a donc été
retoquée par le conseil constitutionnel
est ce que c'est un camouflet pour la
majorité en tous cas c'est un point de
vigilance d'abord je pense que comme
tout le monde il faut prendre acte des
décisions du conseil constitutionnel et
au fond n'a pas forcément aller commenté
simplement à regarder sur quel fondement
il a décidé de censurer tel ou tel
dispositif en particulier dans ce texte
le fait que le juge d'interviews
cependant l'aïe est dans les
dispositions restent quand même le
problème qui était celui auquel
voulaient répondre cette proposition
dois-je rappeler c'est une proposition
de loi qui était celui d'essayer de
lutter contre les contenus haineux sur
sur internet
je constate ceci étant depuis depuis
lors puisque c'est un texte qui avait un
certain une certaine antériorité que les
plateformes et un certain nombre
d'opérateurs commencent à se poser la
question des contenus qui met on voit
bien les débats qui aux états unis avec
le président trump pour faire en sorte
que des contenus qui paraît souhaitent
des fausses nouvelles
pour pas employer le terme anglais ou
des contenus qu'ils sentent europe et ne
puisse être tirées donc c'est aussi la
responsabilité des plateformes s'arrête
interrogera sur le texte ça me permet de
dire au passage que dans les décisions
du conseil constitutionnel il faut
accepter toutes les décisions du conseil
constitutionnel je vois certains se
réjouir de telle ou telle décision et
après mettre en cause des autres
décisions du conseil constitutionnel moi
je suis respectueux en général il ya eu
des dispositions le conseil
constitutionnel avait été saisi par
exemple sur la sortie de l'état
d'urgence ou sur un certain nombre de
dispositions législatives et j'entendais
un certain nombre de responsables
publics ou le responsable politique
remettre en cause des décisions du
conseil constitutionnel les décisions du
conseil constitutionnel c'est un tout
c'est le juge suprême au fond des lois
et donc il faut respecter le conseil
constitutionnel dans ses décisions mais
dans toutes ses décisions ça fait partie
du respect des institutions pour revenir
à la loi via quand on voit la décision
du conseil constitutionnel est ce qu a
connu un problème de préparation avec
cette lan sans doute peut-être un poème
de regard en tout cas sur la manière
dont on pouvait aborder cette question
ça nous ça nous invite à réfléchir sur
les dispositions législatives
sauf au conseil constitutionnel lisant
hier sa décision il dit sur le fond les
motivations sont assez juste après sur
les outils il faut il travailler
différemment
donc c'est drôle de préparer la loi la
part des lits en règle générale de toute
façon il faut qu'on ait tous ces pas sur
ce texte là une vigilance particulière
sur la conformité des lois en même temps
je vaux je vois bien j'ai été
parlementaire la volonté toujours de
dire c'est peut-être constitutionnel ça
n'est peut-être pas est au fond le juge
constitutionnel il est là pour dire le
droit et le droit constitutionnel est ce
que du coup une nouvelle loi est en
préparation
écoutez c'est une décision qui date
d'hier l'envisager on parle
à ce stade non mais la question c'est de
regarder comment on essaie de résoudre
le problème auquel n'était pas la loi
confère une loi ou corée qu'un problème
est qu'on peut pas laisser les choses en
l'état
il me semble qu'il ya quand même un
sujet sur la diffusion de contenus
haineux et qu'on voit bien dans le
moment dans lequel on vit qu'il ya un
sujet de diffusion sur des plateformes
sur les réseaux sociaux de contenu est
nommé qui est une question qui est posée
aux législateurs et autres hauts
responsables publics mais aussi à ceux
qui hébergent ces plateformes est donc
oui il ya une question ce n'est pas
parce que la disposition législative
principal de ce texte a donné lieu à ce
jugement du conseil constitutionnel que
les sujets qui sont sur la table
disparaissent ce sont les sénateurs qui
avaient alerté qui avait saisi le
conseil constitutionnel jean raymond
ligonnet le sénateur républicain qui est
à votre place ya quelques minutes 10
cette décision du conseil
constitutionnel c'est une fois plus
illustration que le gouvernement
n'écoute pas assez le scénariste qu'il a
raison mais des décisions du conseil
constitutionnel sénateurs hugonnet le
sait mieux que moi aussi bien que moi
des décisions du conseil constitutionnel
qui viennent disent peut censurer telle
ou telle disposition c'est comme pas une
nouveauté qui date d'hier
il est arrivé sous d'autres mandature
ceux d'autres législatures comme conseil
constitutionnel j'ai même vu un projet
de loi de finances dont une partie avait
été c'était sous lé président sarkozy
avait été censurée par le conseil
constitutionnel est ce que c'est vous
aviez écouté la version du sénat les
sénateurs vous n'en seriez pas là
tout le monde n'a pas raison d'un bloc
où tout le monde apparaît octore d'un
autre bloc je pense que c'est un
dialogue entre le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale que les choses se font
correctement et ça nécessite de le faire
autant que faire se peut de manière
correcte
il faut respecter les décisions du
conseil constitutionnel et de
l'actualité sujet pose en celte et
violence
qu'est ce que ça dit que l'état du pays
ça ne dit pas des choses que l'état du
pays ça deale des choses de l'état de
nos pays de nos démocraties parce qu'on
voit bien dans beaucoup de démocraties
l'émergence de la violence est un
élément plus profond et plus accrue que
nous n'avons jamais connu
je dis qu'il faut faire d'abord
attention au fait que dans nos propos et
dans nos paroles la brutalité des mots
et parfois la violence des mots elle
entraîne je pas dit qu'elle est là
crédité mais elle elle met dans la tête
d'un certain nombre de gens que c'est la
voie du débat et démocratique c'est la
voie de la violence
et moi je pense que c'est une erreur
nous responsables publics il faut que
dans nos prises de position nous soyons
à la fois ferme et en confrontation
politique parce que c'est la démocratie
mais il faut faire attention aux mots
c'est la première chose deuxièmement
nous sommes dans une société qui est
assez est assez violente
c'est la question qui est posée
d'ailleurs sur un certain nombre de
plateformes on voit que parfois sont
relayés des attitudes violentes et on en
a fait on en fait l'apologie si nous
sommes dans une société violente il faut
qu'on essaie de respecter il faut le cas
shalit est entre nous le cadre dit jean
marc fesneau est quand même assez
symptomatique
marine le pen demande une commission d'
enquête sur ces violences faisant penser
qu'on est libre elle de demander une
commission denquête si elle le veut la
commission denquête j'invite à ce qu'on
laisse faire l' enquête
je constate qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'interpellations quand les lieux mais
je ne résume pas la question de la
violence au sujet aux faits qui se sont
déroulés à dijon qui sont des faits très
graves qui sont le fait d'une bande de
bandes qui se sont affrontées deux
bandes qui n'était pas d'ailleurs
résidente de dijon pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux il ya des enquêtes
qui sont en cours il ya des
interpellations qui ont eu lieu avant
les commissions d'enquêté sont faits à
lenquête laissons faire les policiers
laissons faire la justice pour qu'elle
procède aux essais trop c'est une
mauvaise idée une commission
parlementaire à pied une commission
denquête elle est là pour regarder me
semble-t-il ce que peuvent être une fois
les faits établis une fois les faits
avérés une fois la distance un peu
nécessaire passer pour regarder ce qui
peut avoir été des dysfonctionnements on
est à sept à huit jours il serait bien
que les commissions d'enquêté je crois
que c'est ce qu'elles font d'ailleurs
jusqu'à lors se substitue pas aux
enquêtes il faut laisser faire les
enquêtes il faut que la justice passe il
faut que la police puisse faire son
travail et à partir de là peut-être ya
des enseignements entrée en tirer à ce
moment là c'est l'objectif d'une
commission d'enquêté s'est passé
politique de la peur de marine le pen de
demander
est ce que ça vous étonne en tout cas
pas moi marine le pen va aux quatre
coins de la france là où il ya des
difficultés alors ça c'est une facilité
d'une opposante qui fait feu de tout
bois si je peux dire pour essayer d'
attiser ou de profiter des situations
politiques la situation qui a dit jean
et une situation suffisamment grave pour
que les gens qui se considèrent comme
des responsables et le mou responsable
n'est pas un vain mot et c'est de
résoudre les situations et de ne pas se
tirer parti des situations parce que je
comprends que vous lui reprochez de
entretenir cette violence vous donnez
pas dit ce qu'elles veulent pas
non je n'ai pas d'enfant vous parliez
tout à l'heure je dis je disais qu'elle
elle se saisit de toute situation pour
en tirer
essayer d'en tirer un profit politique
mais par ailleurs collectivement ils ne
s'adressaient pas particulièrement mais
là elle je pense qu'il faut qu'on fasse
attention dans le débat public a employé
des mots qu'ils soient les mots de
l'apaisement et pas se les mots des mots
de la confrontation entre tel et tel
citoyen je pense que ça serait une heure
qui n'est pas toujours le cas de la part
des partis politiques ce qui n'est pas
toujours le cas de pas lesquels
notamment mais je vais pas faire une
liste des partis politiques je suis pas
là pour dresser le tableau et faire le
tableau d'honneur si je peux dire de
ceux qui ils font défaut à ce qu'elle me
semble-t-il dans une république et dans
ceux qui respectent la république et qui
respecte la démocratie de faire
attention aux mots ce que je pense que
dans une société qui est extrêmement
éruptive et quand je dis une société
c'est pas qu'une société française une
société mondiale qui est extrêmement
éruptif je pense que la responsabilité
que nous avons c'est de dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont d'essayer de
résoudre les problèmes et de ne pas
attiser les querelles toujours en
rapport avec ces événements de dijon
bruno retailleau cette fois le patron
des sénateurs les républicains va
déposer une proposition de loi visant à
faciliter l'expulsion des étrangers
délinquants est ce que vous la
soutiendrai je n'ai pas les dispositions
qui sont proposés par bruno retailleau
dans l'es13 nous permettrait une petite
petite digression d envoyer on dit qu'il
faut faire la loi et prendre le temps de
faire la loi il ya un événement il ya
huit jours et ont fait une proposition
de loi du jour après est-ce qu'il faut
pas prendre un peu de temps pour
regarder ces dispositifs des
dispositions législatives on va bien la
question qui est posée est évidemment
comme si c'est trop tôt la part je
m'étais dit que c'était trop tôt jeudi
je fais une digression a déjà envoyé le
temps de la loi parfois n'ai pas le
temps de l'actualité donc faut peut-être
prendre le temps et regarder les choses
il ya déjà des outils qui existent
d'ailleurs
et donc je n'ai pas les dispositions je
crois que bon nombre de présidents
retailleau a posé un principe on
regardera les dispositions enfin je veux
dire il faut regarder les choses en
temps et en heure et pas forcément sous
le feu de l'actualité parce que je
trouve que dans ces cas là on prend
toujours le risque d'être un peu trop
sous le feu de l'actualité
on va parler de la relance d'économie
question qui inquiète les français
cet après cris cette crise économique il
ya plusieurs budgets rectificatifs qui
ont été présentés par le gouvernement
pour faire face à cette crise économique
et à ces chiffres qui s'aggrave de la
dette du déficit est ce qu aura un autre
budget rectificatif au nous en sommes au
troisième pfr qui va donc être débattue
à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
ensuite durant le mois de juin et le
mois de juillet après on rentre dans le
projet de loi de finances ce tout court
je ne crois pas à l'heure sauf événement
imprévu vous savez on est dans un sens
un comme on dirait dans un moment
politique dans un moment économique et
sociale dans un moment sanitaire qui est
un moment qui n'est l'inédit totalement
inédit totalement extraordinaire au sens
premier du terme mais je pense est la
priorité de l'ancien réfectoire est dans
un pl f qui interviendra à l'automne et
qui permettra pour le coup de projeter
les choses pour la pour l'année 2000 21
l'europe aussi s'intéresse à la relance
les états doivent se prononcer sur une
relance commune
on évoque la possibilité d'un impôt
communautaire
vous êtes de longue date un militant
européen qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alors d'abord saluer le travail et le et
salué l'action du président de la
république je le dis quand même parce
que nous partions de très loin il y
avait un certain nombre de pays
européens je pense à un certain nombre
de pays du nord mais même l'allemagne
qui n'était pas favorable à ce qu'une
mutualisation au fond la relance et
d'une certaine façon que la madame
merkel qui a débloqué la situation
c'était évidemment lambertz et ils
n'avaient pas entendu dire que nous
avions était tout seul et que nous
avions seule avancée mais reconnaissons
aussi reconnaissant les choses qu'elles
se sont passées c'est le président de la
république qui a été à l'initiative et
reconnaissons que le président de la
république depuis son élection
d'ailleurs avait été l'un des fondements
de sa de sa de sa campagne de 2017 est
un ardent défenseur de l'europe et
essaie de faire avancer l'europe pour
que pour les citoyens elles répondent
aux questions concrètes qu'ont les
citoyens devant eux et après on a besoin
de partenaires
et c'est quand même bien de convaincre
des partenaires et c'est bien comme
madame merkel mais il nous aura pas
échappé que j'ai plutôt le sentiment
et ce n'est pas une critique parce que
la construction européenne s'est fait de
compromis mais reconnaissons que la
position allemande est une position qui
a plutôt évolué vers nous que nous
verrons et donc on a fait oeuvre
collective et personne n'a gagné c'est
des citoyens européens quand gagner et
donc la question que vous posez sur un
impôt comment ce qui serait une grande
nouveauté un certain oui je vois qu'ils
aient un certain nombre de questions qui
sont sur la table
il faut voir les solutions parce qu'on
voit bien que la difficulté d'un impôt
européen c'est que ça peut être vécu
évidemment par les européens comme
quelque chose de négatif
la question des moyens n'est pas délié
de la question de qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait et je pense que c'est dans un blog
global qu'on regardera les choses
c'est un des éléments qui est sur la
table y en a d'autres qui peuvent être
le qui peuvent être sur la table il ya
des éléments de de prise en charge de la
dette
on verra quelles sont les voies et
moyens pour le faire ceci dit que le
budget européen
quand vous regardez à l'échelle
continentale ce qu'il est il est assez
faible par rapport à la somme des
budgets nationaux que puisse se poser la
question c'est pas forcément un impôt
supplémentaire c'est peut-être des
ressources qu'on distribue différemment
vis-à-vis de l'europe puisse être une
question oui c'est une question parce
que je pense qu'on peut pas à la fois
demander à l'europe d'agir ici sur les
questions sanitaires d'agir ici sur la
lutte contre le changement climatique
ici sur les transports ici sur la crise
économique et en même temps de dire tout
ça se fait à budget strictement constant
parce que sinon voyez bien sûr qu'on
bute pascal moi vous faire des priorités
à ressources constantes
évidemment on peut pas faire plus et
donc il ya une question qui est posée
qu'il posait tous les européens sur
cette question de la relance avec des
propositions des sénateurs les
républicains plomb de rebond selon leurs
termes avec notamment un passage aux 37
heures le retour du travailler plus pour
gagner plus est ce que pour vous il faut
s'attaquer aux 35 heures non mais déjà
il ya eu un certain nombre
d'assouplissements qui ont été mis en
place avec un certain nombre de
discussions qui se font vous pourrez des
entreprises je me méfie toujours de l'un
des exercices qui constitue pour les uns
a rétabli et c est faux à le maintenir
pour les autres à travailler plus pour
gagner plus que j'en ai le sentiment que
c'est quand même une crise très profonde
que nous vivons un moment absolument
historique de ce point de vue là que
nous revenions chacun avec les idées
avec lesquelles nous étions en entrant
dans cette crise
me laisse toujours un peu circonspect je
suis pas sûr que ce soit c'est un moment
tout à fait inédit je suis pas sûr qu'il
faille y retrouver les solutions que
nous avions strictement mois de février
parce qu'au fond cette proposition là
elle était existantes comme d'autres sur
d'autres sujets et pour le coup pour les
autres sur l'ailé gauche de l'hémicycle
bon je crois qu'il ya des
assouplissements qui sont nécessaires on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui la question et
d et au fond de questions de relance il
ya des choses à retenir des propositions
de dessinateur en regardant les
analysera ya sans doute des points de
convergence après faut qu'on fasse un
exercice de vérité et de lucidité
collective il ya beaucoup de
propositions qui sont des propositions
le des plans supplémentaires
je vois que je constate que personne ne
manque d'imagination en ce domaine et
c'est tant mieux parce qu'il faut de
l'imagination il faut qu'on puisse faire
converger les imaginations après il ya
des contingences budgétaires
c'est à dire qu'il faudra qu'on fasse
des priorités et donc il faudra qu'on
choisisse le président la république
dans son intervention dans son
allocution dimanche dernier adressé un
certain nombre de perspectives il faudra
aussi que dans ce cadre là on essaye de
trouver des points de convergence mais
par postulat être pas les priorités pour
est bon mais par postulat jeu je pense
qu'il faut regarder toujours avec
intérêt voire bienveillance dès lors que
c'est fait de bonne foi les propositions
qui viennent d'horizons qui ne sont pas
ceux de la majorité présidentielle parce
qu après tout peut-être que dans le
moment inédit dans lequel nous vivons
que nous puissions les uns et les autres
faire oeuvre de responsabilité et
d'oeuvres commune vers le pays
moi je trouve que c'est une bonne idée
qu'on verra marc fesneau se remet d'une
crise comme ca de la caisse que ce que
vous dites aux français ses 4 ans 5 ans
10 ans je suis pas économiste
on voit bien que les économies d'abord
débattre beaucoup de savoir si la cour
va être envie ou pas enlever c'est à
dire si le rebond très très rapide
je pense que structurellement il ya des
secteurs qui en ont pour plusieurs
années je pense au secteur des
transports au particulière au nautic je
pense au secteur du tourisme parce que
profondément peut-être ça va changer les
choses c'est assez dépendant aussi de
qu'est ce qu'il adviendra de ce virus
parce que on voit bien qu'il ya des
foyers de résurgence l'occasion de dire
que quand même je trouve que nous avons
dans le dé confinement était nous a
parfois reproché beaucoup de prudence et
c est encore le sim virus qui circulent
mais pour l'instant le virus et
l'épidémie est maîtrisé et donc qu'il
faut c'est aussi avec ce regard là qu'il
faudra poser les choses
c'est sans doute un temps assez long
pour se remettre d'une crise comme
celle-là c'est une crise beaucoup plus
profonde que celle de 2008 on revient
peut-être plutôt 80 ou 100 ans en
arrière pour avoir une crise qui soit
comparable
ça n'est pas une crise c'est une crise
qu'il ya un accident lié à une pandémie
ce n'est pas une crise structurelle au
fond mais c'est une crise qui va poser
des questions très lourde un certain
nombre de secteurs donc on peut mettre
un certain temps et c'est pour ça que
notre responsabilité collective ces deux
il ya des étapes électorales
il ya des opposants il ya des gens qui
sont dans la majorité mais je pense que
nous devons devant les français c'est
valable en france comme dans toutes les
grandes démocraties faire oeuvre commune
parce que ce que nous avons devant nous
c'est quand même une crise économique et
donc social qui va être très lourdes
durant cette période cette crise
sanitaire le gouvernement a beaucoup
gouverner par ordonnance est ce que
maintenant il faut revenir à un
fonctionnement normal du parlement ça
pas forcément plu aux parlementaires ces
ordonnances ils se sont sentis
dépossédés est-ce qu'il faut revenir à
un fonctionnement normal j sommes
revenus d'ailleurs dans le texte que
j'ai eu l'honneur de présenter au nom du
gouvernement sur diverses dispositions
législatives j'ai vu que les
parlementaires à l'assemblée nationale
et au sénat se féliciter du fait que
partant de 40 heures de danse nous
soyons revenus à dix c'était pas une
cenne s'est pas fait contre le
gouvernement c'est pas une victoire 2 le
du parlement contre le gouvernement
c'est un travail collectif que nous
avons fait pour faire en sorte des
scribes dans le dur comme on dit des
dispositions qui étaient encore par voie
d'ordonnancé reconnaissons aussi que
dans le moment que nous avons vécu
parfois les ordonnances peuvent être
utiles parce qu'il avait besoin d'agir
vite et comme touche à des sujets très
complexe et très nombreux il aurait
fallu quasiment autant de textes que
d'ordonnancé et donc dans un dans un
moment législatif qui était un moment
compliqué les ordonnances elles ne sont
pas à jeter si vous me permettez des
expressifs d'expression avec l'eau du
bain
elles sont des outils qui peuvent être
les héros sont des outils qui peuvent
être utiles après falling il faut
limiter leur recours l'object le la
constitution en prévoit l'usagé le
conseil d'état d'ailleurs à plusieurs
reprises sur les projets qui lui étaient
soumis indiqué qu' on ne dévoilait pas
le sens des ordonnances nous a demandés
pour certaines de les inscrire en dur ce
qu'on a fait ça peut parfois être utile
mais c'est mieux quand les
parlementaires peuvent se saisir d'un
point de vue très précise de la
législation et donc nous l'avons fait
dans les récents textes ce sera utile
mais parfois les ordonnances sont aussi
utiles à léon l'assemblée nationale qui
avoue le disait a voté mercredi soir le
prolongement de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire mais les restrictions elles
sont là l'arrêt de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire mais les restrictions sont
prolongées pendant une période la
capacité à caves et sa destruction sont
prolongées alors ça fait quoi
ça fait craindre chez une partie des
parlementaires qu' il y ait une sorte
d'état d'urgence permanent va écouter ce
qu'on pense philippe bas et les têtières
à votre place et le président de la
commission des lois du sénat
c'est un état d'urgence n'ont pas
permanent mais de quatre mois qui ne dit
pas son nom et je crois qu'il faut être
transparent et intellectuellement
honnête dans ce qu'on fait qu'est ce que
vous répondez ya un manque de
transparence
mais je crois que nous sommes
transparents et intellectuellement note
nous essayons de sortir un certain
nombre de dispositions de l'état
d'urgence tel qu'il était votée dans la
loi du 23 mars si j'ai bonne mois et en
même temps on a encore besoin d'outils
voyez bien que les résurgences
épidémique font que nous avons besoin de
disposer encore d'outils qui nous
permettent le cas échéant sur les
rassemblements publics sur les
établissements ouverts au public de
pouvoir procéder à des contingences ou
des restrictions qui permettent de
maîtriser l'épidémie encore c'est autre
chose que ça puisse inquiéter mais moi
je vais vous dire ce qui m'inquiète ce
qui m'inquiète c'est que nous ne
disposions pas d'outils pour faire face
à une résurgence épidémique
le conseil constitutionnel le conseil
d'état se sont prononcés pour partie
pour le conseil constitutionnel et pour
le conseil d'état plus largement dans
les différentes dispositions que nous
avions prévu on a besoin d'outils pour
pouvoir faire face à ce que serait une
résurgence et donc de ne par procédés
forcément il ya des dispositifs on
prolonge jusqu'à quatre mois à quatre
mois d'ailleurs ça c'est à ces n'est pas
une question de prolongation à quatre
mois ça c'est un droit nous verrons à ce
moment là mais il ya un certain nombre
d'endroits on voit bien parfois des
résurgences épidémie qui nécessite des
mesures de restriction vis-à-vis
d'établissement route je disais à
l'instant et qui nécessite de le faire
après je comprends moi je suis un ardent
défenseur le polémiste le président de
la république de des libertés publiques
et donc il faut qu'on tienne cette
exigence de liberté publique auquel fait
référence au fond le président philippe
bas il faut qu'on soit exigeant là
dessus mais en même temps mon inquiétude
première c'est de ne pas disposer de
l'outil qui permettrait en cas de
résurgence épidémique de ne pas faire ne
pas faire face c'est quand même ça une
exigence mais ça ne vient pas excusé
l'idée que évidemment c'est qu'il ya
dedans le le confinement généralisée qui
a été mis en place à partir du 17 mars
il ya des privations de liberté
importantes qui ont été faites que les
scellés que les français ont accepté à
assumer et grâce à eux on a pu maîtriser
l'épidémie y voyez bien que parfois on
est obligé de prendre des dispositions
exceptionnelles
parce que la situation était
exceptionnelle et ni vous ni moi nous
savons ce que sera l'état épidémique du
pays
en france et dans le monde et donc on a
besoin d'être précautionneux me
semble-t-il quelques points sur le
calendrier parlementaire à venir avant
de parler des municipales avec fabrice
je vous demander des réponses assez
rapide d'abord les conclusions de la
convention citoyenne qui doivent se
tenir ce week-end les citoyens qui
doivent rendre leur conclusion est ce
qu'il ya une place prévue dans le
calendrier parlementaire si certaines de
ces propositions doivent passer par la
loi ben voyons bien que les la
convention citoyenne va rendre ses
conclusions où ces dispositions ce
week-end
il faut quand même établir un texte il
faut quand même qu'ils puissent passer
aux conseils détaillés pour respecter
les procédures et les institutions et
donc ça ne donne pas la possibilité au
mois de juillet où est très claire après
ce ré ouvre le champ parlementaire à
l'automne et donc j'imagine qu'à
l'automne vous ferez pas ça c'est le jeu
je crois que le président de la
république a bien l'intention le premier
ministre ont bien l'intention de donner
suite et donnez donnez à la fois crédit
et suite aux propositions qui sont
faites par la convention situe à nous
avait beaucoup reproché les ans est un
gadget au fond voyez bien que nous nous
l'avons fait avec la volonté que de ce
qu'ils sortaient de cette convention
citoyenne nous puissions faire quelque
chose qui puisse être débattu devant le
pays d'autres questions rapides la loi
de bioéthique dont le retour est prévu
en juillet à l'assemblée nationale ça
sera concernant ses taux jeudi à
l'assemblée nationale il ya interruption
des travaux puisqu'il vous aura pas
échappé que dans cette maison il ya il
ya des élections sénatoriales on va
respecter la coutume républicaine qui
fait qu'il n'ya pas de débat est donc
c'est après le sénat reprendra en
octobre après et après on verra dans le
calendrier parlementaire
l'ensemble des textes on verra quel
moment peut être débattu le texte sur la
bioéthique parenthèse d'ailleurs le
sénat reprendra ses travaux en octobre
pour cause d'élection l'assemblée y aura
une session extraordinaire en sait pour
l'instant c'est un décret du ca
appartient au président de la république
c'est un décret du président de l'unfp
public mais il est pas impossible
on verra c'est en fonction des textes là
aussi il ya des choses autour de la
relance puis après nous rentrons dans
une grande séquence budgétaire l'automne
et l'automne français si je peux dire en
termes parlementaire est un automne très
budgétaire et donc il faut qu'on trouve
aussi des lieux enfin des espaces de
temps qui permette de défendre la loi
bioéthique ne sera pas forcément adoptée
par le parlement d'ici la fin de l'année
deux virages moi je ne préempte pas le
temps dont veulent disposer les
parlementaires c'est un texte qui ne
bénéficient pas entre guillemets de la
procédure accélérée il faut laisser le
temps je pense que les débats sont
passées dans de bonnes conditions à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat sans
passion et avec des profondes
divergences entre parlementaires et par
entre les assemblées c'est très bien
c'est un débat démocratique il faut que
ce débat continue à se passer dans ces
conditions là c'est sur quoi nous
verrons dans quelques jours au deuxième
tour des élections municipales quelqu'un
sort dans la commune dont l'éclat
j'étais maire mais dans d'autres
communes il reste finalement assez peu
mais les plus grosses donc c'est très
bien c'est donc du coup c'est important
quelle place pour les centristes
finalement dans cette élection
municipale et par le modem passait rien
au modem en particulier la place qui a
été toujours la leur dans les
territoires le historiquement cette
famille de pensée a toujours eu plutôt
des élus sur les territoires
reconnaissons que l'essentiel du jeu ou
du match s'est joué au premier tour
parce que le premier le deuxième tour
n'est qu'une confirmation une
prolongation au gré des alliances qui
peut se nouer
quel bilan pour le modem alors au
premier tour bon il ya un certain nombre
de maires qui sont élus un certain
nombre d'autres qui sont en bonne
position dans un certain nombre de
départements difficile de faire un bilan
là en tout cas un bilan positif en terme
de nombre de conseillers municipaux qui
sont qui sont élus c'est le travail n'a
pas toujours d'un parti politique de
tous les partis politiques de faire de
ces élections c'est toujours un moment
important de vie démocratique pour le
pays et de vie démocratique pour les
partis c'est l'occasion de faire monter
des générations j'ai commencé comme
conseiller municipal ya un certain
nombre d'années désormais c'est une des
meilleures voix d'apprentissage de la
vie publique que celle de la vie locale
parce que quand même le modem n'a pas eu
du mal à exister pendant ces municipales
mais on ferait une deuxième erreur et
j'ai dû le dire ici sur votre plateau
que de dire les municipales c'est une
affaire du modem des républicains de la
république en marche ou du parti
socialiste d'autres formations
politiques
c'est une halle vézilier pour certains
partis politiques comme les centristes
et le modem en particulier les
municipales sont généralement une
aubaine
oui mais on nous aurons des cons ceux
des conseillers municipaux à ses
nombreux jeux pas le chiffre aujourd'hui
et donc il faut faire un bilan à la fois
dans les communes de plus de 3500 c'est
facile à identifier dans sept qui sont
de plus petite taille mais c'est plutôt
comment dirais-je un cru qui a permis de
faire monter des générations l'intérieur
de la famille centriste et à l'intérieur
du modem en particulier dont je pense
que c'est ce que vous n'avez pas été
lâché par la république en marche
je me lâche et de coût ou ça comment on
peut avoir eu des désaccords ya eu
beaucoup de désaccords ya pas eu d
écoute d allier beaucoup dans un bidon
noms de communes ou des mains qu'on dise
à l'arrivée les élections municipales et
des désaccords partisans des désaccords
partisans comme des trains c'est à dire
qu'on ne voit que ceux qui sont en
retard et jamais ceux qui sont à l'heure
il ya eu beaucoup d'accord je pourrais
vous citer la liste mais je ne veux pas
après que ouvrir une porte qui ferait
vous seriez obligés de compenser la
liste des candidats sur lequel nous
avons un accord sinon je vous fais la
liste tout de suite mais vous allez tant
défaut à près de temps de parole vous
serez obligés de donner un temps de
parole à d'autres donc je connais la
règle
donc je m'y astreins mais il ya beaucoup
d'endroits eu désaccord c'est pas parce
que dans quatre cinq ou six endroits et
parfois il ya eu des désaccords au
premier tour et des convergences au 2e
essai l'immense majorité des cas c'est
plus de 90% des cas 95 % des cas et donc
on a pu travailler ensemble après au
moins je remarque c'est un partenaire
fiable mais il faut qu'on soit pour
comporte réciproquement une forme
d'exigences qui fait qu'on d'abord on
respecte nos sortants on essaie de
converger on peut avoir des désaccords
on les assume
il faut que ça se fasse en bonne
intelligence c'est pas toujours facile
il ya toujours des forces dans les
partis politiques essaient de 2,2 de se
cantonner à s'opposer les uns les autres
le pire poison et ce n'est pas qu'un
poison entre la république en marche et
le modem le pire poison qui peut exister
dans les élections municipales quand on
porte un projet commun c'est la division
et c'est ça qui a été aussi parfois à
l'oeuvre qui a parfois porter des
mauvais fruits si je peux dire au moment
des municipales scellé l'idée de la
division et je pense que les
personnalités doivent se retirer de cet
esprit de division pour pour essayer de
vrais vers le collectif et c'est ça des
gens si beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous